[MUSIC PLAYING]
MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to DataVis DevTalk.
I'm your host, Minhaz Kazi.
Our today's guest
is Mikael Thuneberg.
Mikael is the founder
and CEO of Supermetrics.
Supermetrics is a tool
that fetches marketing data
into Google Data Studio
and other platforms.
Mikael, welcome to the show.
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: Thank you.
Great to be here.
MINHAZ KAZI: So Supermetrics
and Google Analytics
and its developer relations
team have a long history.
And I've heard that there
was also a T-shirt involved
somewhere there.
Can you tell our audience
about that entire story?
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: Sure.
Several years ago, I was working
at the marketing department
of a gaming company.
And my job there was to do
reporting on our marketing
activities.
But a large part of my time
went into copy-pasting numbers
from Google Analytics and
other sources into Excel.
And that was really
time-consuming and boring.
So when the Google
Analytics API came out,
I figured I could use that
to automate that process.
And I did some googling
around the issue,
and I found a forum post by
Nick Mihailovski, who is now
Data Studio PM, saying that
the first person who integrates
the Google Analytics
API with Excel
gets a free Google T-shirt.
And I figured, that's perfect.
I got to solve my own problem,
and I also got a free T-shirt.
So I did a small script
that solves that issue.
And I shared that with Nick,
and Nick said, that's good.
And he sent me the T-shirt.
But even more importantly,
he blogged about my solution.
And that generated
a lot of interest
and led me to quit my job and
then to found Supermetrics.
MINHAZ KAZI: That is amazing.
In what areas does Supermetrics
help its customers, and how?
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: Right.
So marketers-- they
struggle with their data
being spread out in
various different systems.
So they may be doing advertising
on Google, Facebook, Twitter,
LinkedIn.
They have a web analytics
tool such as Google Analytics,
they have a CRM--
various other systems
where they have their data.
And getting the full
picture is difficult.
Many marketers, they still
rely on a manual process
of getting this data together.
So they might be doing
copy-pasting into Excel
like I was doing.
They may be downloading CSVs
and manually merging those
together.
Or they may have hacked
together some scripts
that are unreliable.
What we do is we automate
that process for them.
So we have built
high-quality integrations
through all of these different
advertising and marketing
tools.
And we get that data
together and put that data--
or make the data available into
tools that marketers generally
want to use, such as Google
[INAUDIBLE],, Google Data
Studio, Excel, and others.
MINHAZ KAZI: How is Supermetrics
relevant for your customers?
You mentioned that
Supermetrics is
pulling in data from all
of these different sources
and making it
available on the tools.
So how are your users using
that data in Data Studio?
MIKAEL THUNEBERG:
Yes, so usually when
you advertise on
different channels,
you want to see a
combined view of how
your campaigns are performing.
So that's one thing they can
do to get a cross-platform view
of their campaign performance.
They can also merge
their advertising data
with their sales data, which
is also an interesting use
case where they say,
OK, our advertising cost
this much and then [INAUDIBLE]
this much revenue based
on the leads we got.
MINHAZ KAZI: And
you've also made
a lot of templates
available for Data Studio
that people can use
with your connectors.
MIKAEL THUNEBERG:
Yes, so what we
do when we create a
connector, we also
want to create a
high-quality template
to go with that connector.
So it's really easy for
users to get started.
So when you start using
any of our connectors,
there's a premade template that
is populated with your data,
so you immediately see
how your data looks like.
Based on a template,
you can then
start doing customizations
and modifying
that fit your particular needs.
MINHAZ KAZI: If an
organization wants
to make their own data available
to their customers for Data
Studio, how can Supermetrics
help them in that area?
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: So if there's
no connector already available
for that particular data
source, there are some options.
We have something called
a custom [INAUDIBLE]
CSP XML connector,
so that you can
use to get data from any
endpoint that provides
data in one of
these three formats,
so [INAUDIBLE], CSP, or XML.
And our connector
takes that data
and processes it into the
format the data studio expects,
so it's really easy to get
that data into Data Studio
and start reporting
straightaway.
That works in many
cases, not all of cases.
So if that doesn't work
for you, the other option
is to contact us, and
we may be able to build
that connector for you.
MINHAZ KAZI: For
Data Studio, we've
seen a lot of users
and developers
who use it purely as a
marketing reporting tool.
But there are also
other users who
are using it not just
as a marketing tool,
but also as a completely
full-fledged PI reporting
solution.
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: Yeah.
MINHAZ KAZI: So what
are your views on this?
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: Yes,
so I think right now
it's still largely used
for marketing purposes.
And a large part of the
community connectors
are also marketing-related.
Data Studios is a
great tool, and it
can be used for other
purposes as well.
And I think that's
an area where we
are expanding to in the future
very, very, very strongly.
So we are soon releasing our
first financial connector,
getting accounting
data into Data Studio.
We are going to
follow up on that
with various other
kinds of connectors
that are not marketing-related.
Accounting, finance,
HR, customer service,
all kinds of different
choices that can
be visualized in Data Studio.
MINHAZ KAZI: How should
small and medium businesses
approach their marketing
reporting and analytics
dashboards?
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: Keep
it simple to start with.
It's easy to get
a bit carried away
with all the cool features that
are available in Data Studio.
You don't want to create a
cluttered dashboard with all
the different chart types.
So I would concentrate on a few
key metrics to [INAUDIBLE] it,
make a really, really
simple dashboard--
big metrics that the
audience understands
and that are actionable.
MINHAZ KAZI: Two years
ago, we didn't really
have a big developer
community around Data Studio.
Since then, we've launched a
community connectors feature,
we're working on
community visualizations,
and more and more
people are getting
interested in building tools and
solutions around Data Studio.
So what would your
advice to someone
who's just starting to build
solutions around this tool?
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: I think Data
Studio is a great platform
for developers.
It's really easy to get started.
The documentation
is really good,
and you've done a
really good job on that.
And also you've got a lot
of support from your team,
obviously, when you
build a connector.
So getting started with building
connectors is really simple,
and I definitely recommend that.
The challenges maybe
then come a bit later.
Data Studio has a large
user base in the millions.
So if your connector
really takes off,
you may get a lot of users.
And that brings new challenges
that you then need to tackle,
such as how do you handle the
traffic flows with the rate
limits that are in
the data source APIs
that you connect to, so you
don't go over any limits that
are in the source APIs?
You need to do a lot of
caching in different places
to tackle that.
You need to have
monitoring in place.
You need to be able to handle
all kinds of edge cases
with the queries, such as,
what if your query takes
over a minute to run when
the timeout for HTTP request
is 1 minute?
So all kinds of
things like this,
you need to then
start thinking about.
But to get started,
it's really easy.
MINHAZ KAZI: Mikael, thanks
again for being on the show.
MIKAEL THUNEBERG: Thanks.
Was great being here.
MINHAZ KAZI: You can check out
the Supermetrics connectors
in the Data Studio gallery.
Link is in the
description below.
Make sure to subscribe to
the GCP YouTube channel.
And you can always visit our
website at developers.googl
e.com/datastudio.
Until next time, keep
building more Vis.